I quit drinking back in October for 18
years uh-huh I've got 17 and 1 12 years
to go in order for it to be true I'm
going to stop drinking while my while my
son's living in my house just because I
don't totally love the way I do it being
with him the time that I have with him
is really precious and he's getting to
an age where he really does need me all
the time in the morning I did one school
run uh one day where I dropped him off
at school I wasn't driving but I was
hung over and that was enough for me I
didn't love that one yeah So the plan is
you know I'm only going to do it time
until get him off to college and then
like move to a Vineyard and then spend
the back half of my life completely
sosed happy sundrenched that's the plan